[Music]
when I first got into education a
quarter century ago it was frightening
ly easy to find teachers and schools who
shrugged off responsibility for kids who
weren't learning it was too easy to
blame the home or the family happily
things have changed today when you go to
schools and systems you find teachers
being asked to take responsibility for
every one of their charges that's a
fantastic thing here's the problem
teachers don't work alone they work in
partnership with families with students
we need to make sure that teachers are
not being asked to shoulder the whole
burden the Kipp charter schools has a
wonderful model of how to deal with this
they have a commitment to excellence
that is signed by teacher students and
parents which they are all asked to take
responsibility for making sure the
student succeeds what we need are
schools where teachers are asked to do
all that they can for every child but
that also expect parents and families to
step up and be partners for the schools
to ensure that each child is well served
to learn more about my take on school
reform check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like a EEI scholars
to cover in 60 seconds